在他心里门儿亲，
他跟哪个女的有没有暧昧，
有没有那个消息的传递，
他心里门亲，
你看他的手机，
他没说什么月格的话呀，
你看他俩也没抱在一起，
肯啊，
但他俩那个暧昧的情愫，
他心里可清楚了，
他就是享受那个，
仅此而已。
我跟我男朋友相处了三年半，
近几个月吧，
他就是也就是由于工作关系吧，
组建了一个小团体，
是三男一女的小团体，
他们就是经常一起出去玩，
我就比较介意这个事情，
因为我觉得那个女生不是很有边界感，
但是我的这个男朋友就是觉得我在束缚她，
说是我自私管束他，
她出去玩不带你呀，
还是带你啊，
开始是带我的，
但是在我这个过程中，
我也是会感觉到会让我不舒适，
就是我男朋友会经历的就是照顾我的感受，
但是那个女生就是她确实是一个没有边界感的人，
她会跟其他的男生拍拍打搭那种吧，
她虽然就是在我面前没有跟我男朋友这样，
但是就是会让我心里很不舒服，
而且就是他们工作关系，
晚上的时候有的时候还会一起组建这个团体，
他们还会一起聚在一起，
就是去吐槽今天的八卦什么的，
会让我心里不舒，
我也不知道怎么样去调节这个事情，
关于这个女生的小事儿吧，
我们就会经常发生争吵，
女孩儿有男朋友吗？
那女孩儿结婚了，
就是是刚刚结婚的，
她老公也在那个小团体吗？
她不在，
他们44个人，
然后这个女生有。
公，
其中有一个男生也有老婆，
这个女生跟另一个已婚的男士，
他俩有点不清不楚的关系，
那么可以两个友，
就是可以单独的去八九点钟去KTV，
他们两个人的那种，
所以我就觉得这个女生特别的没有边界感，
我一说这个事儿，
我一提这个事儿，
我男朋友就觉得我在贬击他的朋友，
就觉得是我的问题，
我有病，
因为他们这些种种的事情吧，
我俩就频繁争吵嘛，
然后争吵之后我就觉得每一次都他都是在维护他，
我虽然能知道她在让我去融入，
但是我融入不了，
导致他现在是什么状态呢？
就是会瞒着我跟他们出去玩儿，
我就更受不了了，
然后之后我俩又吵了一架，
目前一个月没有联系了，
真心话，
姐妹们啊，
这是龙飞姐我自己的切身的感受，
我跟你们说过吗？
我对象没朋友，
日子过得老爽了，
老自在了，
啥事儿没有？
你找这个男的的话，
他享受的是跟几个女的暧昧不清，
她享受的是女人为他争风吃醋，
觉得自己老有魅力了，
就觉得某种程度上，
你一方面发疯，
一方面追查他的那个下落在哪里，
追查他在哪里吃饭了喝酒了啊，
他一方面在朋友面前抱怨，
另一方面他心里很美了，
他觉得你看那么多女的为我要死要活的，
那么多女的为我争风吃醋的，
如果一个男的他享受的是这些事儿的话，
他哪有那么多时间精力去想着我怎么对孩子负责任，
我怎么对老婆以后过好日子啊？
我怎么能换更大的房子，
我怎么能换更好的车呢？
他的时间精力都花在说我怎么能让两个女的对我要。
死不活的爱我爱的要死啊，
他心里都花在上面了，
他可享受了，
我不太知道他对这个女生，
因为这个女生她是已婚嘛，
然后他还是某嫂，
我不知道他对他是什么情感，
但是我很明显的感觉到，
就他有什么事儿都愿意，
就现在就不太愿意跟我说他的事情，
因为我们已经相处了三年半嘛，
就是这几个月就是因为这个事情争吵嘛，
他以前就是在我的认知里面，
他是一个挺有毕业感的人，
就他我就非常的信任他，
然后不知道为什么，
就是有了这个人之后，
就是变成了这样，
我能接近他，
不会做出越格的那一步，
但是感觉他的心思不在我这儿了，
你想问我啥问题啊，
就现在就是因为工作调动问题有一些问题，
然后他的情绪也非常不好，
我想知道是我的要求太多了，
是我没有把这个事情处理好，
还是说就是我们两个走不到一起了，
都没有说可以去补救这个感情的必要，
我不认为他是今天变成这样的，
他一直都是这样的人，
只是你今天才发现而已。
有没有补救的必要取决于什么啊？
取决于说就这个男人是你所接触的所有男人当中赚钱最多的嘛，
能力最强的吗？
最有前途的嘛，
家庭条件最好的嘛，
你缺了他了之后，
你再也找不着了吗？
如果说你自己家庭条件不好，
你得靠着他吃，
靠着他喝，
你得靠着他才能住上你心仪的房子，
靠着他你才能找着工作的话，
那你没办法，
你只能委曲求全，
人只能图一头，
他的家庭还行，
我的工资是比他高的，
就是我自己是有能力的，
因为我现在。
已经岁数挺大了，
我快30了，
然后这段感情我也付出了挺多，
感觉有一点舍不得，
然后觉得有点心里过不去，
那你就要降低对婚姻的期待，
就是从今天开始，
从跟龙飞姐聊完天开始，
从此刻开始降低对未来婚姻的期待，
就是他的手机也让我看，
你就说这种状态下是什么样的状态呀？
姐其实他心里门儿亲，
他跟哪个女的有没有暧昧，
有没有那个定消息的传递，
她心里门情，
你看她的手机，
她没说什么月哥的话呀，
你看她俩也没抱在一起啃啊，
但她俩那个暧昧的情愫，
她心里可清楚了，
她就是享受那个，
仅此而已，
因为她不是母嫂嘛，
她跟老公不是在外面嘛，
就是我能不能告诉她老公，
她的老婆跟别的人有暧昧关系，
如果你要决定跟你的男朋友继续过下去的话，
你要发这个消息的话，
他就会埋了一个雷，
那将来的话，
人家踹你的时候，
哎，
埋了一个，
如果是哼，
我过不好，
我不想跟你好了，
但是我也不想让好过是吧，
我也让你一地鸡毛，
你如果决定不想跟这个男的好了，
那可以啊，
我的性格被破坏了，
我也不想让你好过啊，
他们团体中的这个女的跟另一个男的他俩都是已婚的，
他俩这关系就特别暧昧，
就他俩肯定是有事儿的，
你得有证据你拍照，
每天女的拍个照就是你光说不行，
我这人比较坏啊，
我这人就又阴险又毒辣，
有又坏，
我爆品又强，
我要是想。
跑了的话，
哎，
我每天就是他们唱歌啊什么的啊，
我就知道他们在哪的话，
我就拍照，
我拍照还净找那种借位的，
我还净找那种一看他俩就暧昧的不行的，
他俩都恨不得抱一块儿，
但我就拍照，
我就不会偷偷录音，
我就放着，
所以不让我好过，
我也不想让你好过，
以前我没有想过这个事情，
就以前他们俩就是在那个KTV里面，
就是那么搭肩呀，
那个女的给那男的搭白头发呀什么的，
就是这种，
哎呀，
大家喝的高兴啊，
开只是起到一个调，
就是提醒的作用，
那不行，
那你这样发短信的话，
你这个人就是蠢，
又蠢又坏，
你没证据，
你发短信你不是又蠢又坏，
没有证据跟人家那个男的看来的话，
那你就属于挑拨人家夫妻关系了，
就因为他不是魔嫂嘛，
所以我还担忧一点，
就是怕有一些责任，
你怕谁有责任啊，
我呀，
我要是拿不出来实际性的证据，
因为他不是谋嫂嘛，
你你应该是没有什么责任的，
但是你必须要有，
真有证据的话，
你可以发，
你没证据的话，
你就别做这事儿啊，
好的就是降低对婚姻的期待，
降低对那个以后夫妻两个人感情亲密度的期待，
我就图你说家庭条件也不错，
我图你这个人也能挣钱，
我图你这个人有前途，
我就降低对你的期待啊，
要么呢，
你就是换一个，
就真的是属于那种，
他心思不在那个，
多跟几个女的搞暧昧，
他心思不在这些事儿上，
他心思在怎么能够让他自己变得更优秀啊，
组建了家庭之后，
怎么能够创造更好的物质条件给家里面的孩子呀？
怎么能保障以后的生活呀，
你就找这样的人啊，
好的，
嗯，
是好，
就这样啊，
拜拜，
嗯，
你们发现没有，
就是一般情况下说两口子关系挺好的，
那样的家庭啊，
他往往是属于两口子社会关系都可简单了，
没有什么朋友，
这两口子下了班就回家了，
做饭啊，
炒菜呀，
带孩子啊，
两口子一心都不在家里，
但是你知道吗？
你周围的那些亲戚朋友、
兄弟同事，
他们可未必能见得你们两口子的时候关系这么好，
甚至有的父母都得挑拨一下你们两口子的关系有没有了，
就因为你们两口子关系一好了，
减少了其他的社交了，
其他人就从你们两口子身上都再也讨不到便宜了，
就要破坏你们两口子之间的这样一个团结。
记得点赞关注哦。